We now continue the Toa Nuva's fight for the Super Family.
Who's next to challenge me?
Yes, your name is Onua Nuva.
See, I switched Morca and Conra and gave them new masks.
I see.
Alright, gotta get ready.
You know what, I don't feel like battling too much today.
Charge up!
I ain't even gonna fire this at you.
Powerful attacks, Quilva and Kopaka Nuva out.
Eh, darn.
Boy, I sure hope Dr. Seinyor's doing good.
I knocked two of your ma- that attack knocked two of your masks off.
Alright, let's battle.
Grrrr.
I'm getting mad.
My arm back.
Super attack.
I knocked off two.
Get them infected masks off.
Hey, stop drilling my head.
You taste horrible.
Man, I got a sore throat today.
Alright, Hyper Slash.
Catch him.
Destroy him.
Use pig missile.
It failed.
Bounder.
Oh, Hachi Nuva.
I bet you're just as-
Yeah, Wakuda, I can kick with both legs now.
Just gotta do some-
I just-
My leg's twisted around.
There.
I'm all ready.
And I've got an arm weapon now.
Yes, I do.
What should I use?
Speed or, uh, I don't know.
Check out my weapon.
Bowser's.
Bowser's brain is inside your skull.
I only want to kick with one leg.
Now I just need to put my mask on.
And, hey, I didn't even have my armor on.
Just play this upside down.
It needs-
Wait a minute.
It doesn't need to be.
Super kick.
Soccer kick.
I'm gonna hit you on the head.
No.
I'm gonna hit you on the head with my foot.
Okay.
Got you.
So we beat him.
Let's rock the house.
The sword is installed.
I need it.
Haha, you can't get it.
Come to me.
It's battle.
You missed.
This won't miss.
But it didn't hurt me much.
Formation.
Check out my sword.
Man, that took away a lot of health.
Scrape your nose, because my sword is broken.
Swords have hooks on the end.
I'm going to meditate.
Ow.
Mrow.
Head came off.
My- rather, my mask.
Said, those- those wings are like whips.
Hmm?
Super slash.
Hey dude, that's me.
Uh, let's make him more frustrated.
Weakness is my temper.
I shouldn't have said-
Let's make him more mad.
Ready for that.
Making my strength stronger.
Strength is my temper.
But it hurts.
I'm all twisted.
Ugh.
I need to meditate some more.
Uh.
Feet.
Yum.
Mmm.
I must meditate.
Again?
Ow.
Mrow.
Let's go.
Ew.
I am trained in fencing.
Block.
Ew.
I must medicate.
Go ahead and do what you're supposed to do.
You're like-
I'm kidding.
You're not-
Sorry for the inconvenience.
I'll help him later.
I gotta destroy Con-Ra first.
I mean, Mwaka.
Where did he go, that coward?
It's TV.
Kuda.
At least I'm on the beach instead of- for the last few hours of my life.
Get away, you freak.
Ugh.
The super family has defeated me for the final ti- I can't- I can't- I can't- I can't-
I don't know what it is, but I can't say it.
Get away, you freaking stooge.
Ooh.
You make-
Crabby.
Fairy.
Oh, no.
Oh.
Ow.
Ooh.
Ah.
E.
Ow.
That's the end of the show.
Oh.
Grandma.
Pikachu.
Get the-
I forgot to tell you.
Um.
Join us for our next video.
The super family.
Call.
You'll find out what the super family is all about.
The super family has a new- This will be our longest video, actually.
Stay tuned.
I had that.
But I can't wait for the next movie to start.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, I turned it off.
I did.
All right.
Okay, you can-